Julia's 13. Jane and Ella are 14. And when they came to our studio for an interview, they did this thing they do all the time when they hang out. They take pictures of themselves. And-- no surprise-- they post them to Instagram.
Julia 13岁。Jane和Ella 14岁。当她们来到我们的工作室接受采访时，她们做了她们平时待在一起时常做的事情。她们给自己拍照。而且——不出所料——她们把照片发到了Instagram上。
There you go.
给你。
No, retake it. It's really bad.
不行，重拍。这张太丑了。
Jane, calm down.
Jane，冷静点。
It doesn't matter, OK? This is what happens every time.
没关系，好吗？每次都这样。
I'm just gonna post it and we'll see--
我这就发上去，然后我们看看——
We'll see what happens.
我们看看会发生什么。
--how quickly everything comes in.
——看看大家回复得有多快。
So what's your prediction on what's going to happen?
那你预测会发生什么？
Usually there's at least-- usually there's two likes in a minute. But I don't know, because people might not be up yet.
通常至少会有——通常一分钟内会有两个赞。但我不知道，因为大家可能还没起床。
People aren't-- there's--
人们没有——有——
It was 11:00 in the morning on a day with no school, not prime time for posting photos at all. Nighttime is usually when you get the most likes and comments. But, you know, 11:00 AM. A minute passes. No response on the photo they took in the studio. And then?
那是放假期间上午11点，根本不是发照片的黄金时间。晚上通常是点赞和评论最多的时候。但是，你知道，上午11点。一分钟过去了。她们在工作室拍的照片没有得到任何回应。然后呢？
Oh, wait, three likes.
噢，等等，三个赞。
Oh, three likes.
噢，三个赞。
From Ro--
来自Ro——
From three people. No one's commented yet. One of these is my best friend. OK, another person liked it. Two people.
来自三个人。还没人评论。其中一个是我的好朋友。好的，又有人点赞了。两个人。
Two people. OK, we're getting a lot of likes now.
两个人。好的，我们现在收到很多赞了。
Three. Another person.
三个。又一个人。
How many likes do we have now?
我们现在有多少个赞了？
Six, I think.
我想是六个。
OK, we have one, two, three, four, five, six likes in a minute. That's actually good, Ella.
好的，一分钟内我们有六个赞。这其实不错了，Ella。
What they're waiting for is not just likes and comments but a specific kind of comment. This is probably not going to be news to any of you who have teenage girls in your lives, but I bet lots of you do not know about this. They want comments from other girls, and they say the wording is pretty much always the same.
她们等待的不仅仅是赞和评论，而是一种特定的评论。对于你们当中生活中接触过少女的人来说，这可能不是什么新闻，但我敢说你们很多人并不知道这一点。她们想要其他女孩的评论，而且她们说措辞几乎总是完全一样的。
Gorgeous. Pretty. Stunning.
华丽。漂亮。迷人。
Stunning? Yeah.
迷人？是啊。
You kill it. You're so pretty. So beautiful.
你美极了。你太漂亮了。太美了。
OK, just to be clear, they say this about everybody's selfies, whether or not the selfies are, in fact, stunning or beautiful. This is super-affirming language that is applied equally to every girl, universally. You've heard of bullying online? This is the opposite.
好的，说清楚点，她们会对每个人的自拍都这么说，不管这些自拍实际上是不是真的华丽或美丽。这是一种超级肯定的语言，被普遍地应用在每个女孩身上。听说过网络霸凌吗？这恰恰相反。
A lot of people don't just say pretty. You either say like, Pretty, WTF? Gorgeous, WTF? Perfect.
很多人不仅仅说漂亮。你要么说，漂亮，搞什么鬼？华丽，搞什么鬼？完美。
Like all caps sometimes.
有时全是大写字母。
Um, some people say, like, model. You can add OMG after anything.
嗯，有些人会说，比如，模特。你可以在任何词后面加OMG。
Cutest, like--
最可爱，像——
Yeah.
是啊。
Something "-est."
以“est”结尾的词。
The one word you don't say? "Sexy." They explained you could say "hot," but never "sexy."
唯一不能说的词？“性感”。她们解释说你可以说“火辣”，但绝不能说“性感”。
They are-- there's a different--
她们是——有不同的——
They're the same thing, actually.
其实它们是一回事。
There's a different connotation to "sexy" than there is to "hot."
“性感”和“火辣”的内涵是不一样的。
'Cause, like, it has the word "sex" in it. Sex.
因为，它里面有“性”这个词。性。
Yeah, I think it's the word.
是啊，我想就是这个词。
Like, intercourse.
比如，性交。
Ella!
Ella！
[GIRLS GIGGLE]
[女孩们咯咯笑]
This is not about sex. It's not about boys. It's about girls, and friendship. And it's very repetitive-- the same phrases, over and over. I asked them each to pick a selfie that they'd posted and read the comments.
这与性无关。这与男生无关。这关乎女孩，关乎友谊。而且它非常重复——同样的短语，一遍又一遍。我让她们每人挑一张发过的自拍，然后读出评论。
So I have gorgeous, pretty.
我有华丽，漂亮。
You're so pretty, OMG.
你太漂亮了，OMG。
So pretty.
太漂亮了。
This is so pretty, OMG.
这太漂亮了，OMG。
Heart eyes. So pretty. Heart eyes. Gorgeous. Gorge.
爱心眼。太漂亮了。爱心眼。华丽。美翻了。
You're so pretty, bye.
你太漂亮了，拜。
Cutest.
最可爱。
They say their parents don't understand this. Ella's mom has Instagram, so she sees the pictures and the comments.
她们说她们的父母不理解这一点。Ella的妈妈有Instagram，所以她能看到照片和评论。
She's just like, why? Why? Why is everyone doing this? Like, why are 50 people feeling the need to tell you that you're pretty?
她总是说，为什么？为什么？为什么每个人都非要这么做？为什么50个人都觉得有必要告诉你你很漂亮？
Julia's mom? Same thing.
Julia的妈妈？也是一样。
She's like, why? Why are all these people saying, like, oh, you're so perfect? And my dad just thinks it's funny. He's like, why are these people doing this? Like, it doesn't-- it's kind of stupid. They think it's, like, stupid.
她就像，为什么？为什么所有人都在说，噢，你太完美了？我爸爸觉得这很好笑。他就像，为什么这些人要这么做？这没什么——这有点愚蠢。他们觉得这很愚蠢。
So what's it about? Well, the answer to that question is complicated, and it involves going deep into an intricate language that's going on in the comments. Welcome to WBEZ Chicago. It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
那这到底是为了什么？嗯，那个问题的答案很复杂，而且需要深入了解评论中存在的一套错综复杂的语言。欢迎来到WBEZ芝加哥。这里是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。
Today's program is about status updates of various kinds-- the literal kind, like on Instagram. But most of our show today is about the kind of slow changes in status that happen to adults, that happen usually when people get money or they get recognition, where what happens is, you know, quiet, and slow, and really, is sometimes kind of rude to talk about. Like, when do you say to anybody, "Hey, you're making a lot more money than you used to." Or, "Hey, you're making a lot less money." Or, "You're making a lot more money than me."
今天的节目是关于各种状态更新的——字面意义上的那种，比如在Instagram上。但我们今天节目的大部分是关于成年人生活中缓慢的状态改变，通常发生在人们有了钱或获得认可的时候，发生的事情是安静的、缓慢的，而且说实话，谈论这些有时有点粗鲁。比如，你什么时候会对别人说，“嘿，你比以前赚得多多了。”或者，“嘿，你赚得少多了。”或者，“你赚得比我多多了。”
And that's why I wanted to talk to Jane and Ella and Julia. Because for them, this stuff is not gradual or vague or shameful to talk about. It's happening out in the open, online. They're online all the time, constantly getting updates on the social standing of everybody they know, in detail and at incredible speed. And that's what these Instagram comments are all about, if you know how to read them.
这就是为什么我想和Jane、Ella还有Julia聊聊。因为对她们来说，这些东西不是渐进的、模糊的，或者谈论起来令人羞耻的。它在网上公开发生着。她们一直在线，不断地获取她们认识的每个人的社交地位更新，非常详尽且速度惊人。如果你懂得如何解读，这就是这些Instagram评论的全部含义。
So let's just start right there, with Act 1. Act 1. Finding the Self in Selfie.
所以让我们从这里开始，第一幕。第一幕。在自拍中寻找自我。
So these comments-- you know, you're so beautiful, you're gorgeous, you're cutest-- which look utterly interchangeable to Julia and Ella and Jane's parents, they are in fact a very specific language that tells the girls all kinds of things. And a lot of the meaning in the comments actually has nothing to do with the actual words, whether they say gorgeous, or pretty, or OMG, or whatever. It's about who is doing the commenting, and whether that person likes a photo or comments on the photo-- liking a photo means something totally different than commenting. You comment with somebody you're close to, or who you're trying to get close to. And with a close friend, you kind of have to comment.
所以这些评论——你知道，你太美了，你华丽，你是最可爱的——在Julia、Ella和Jane的父母看来完全是可以互换的，实际上却是一种非常具体的语言，告诉女孩们各种各样的事情。评论中很多含义其实与实际词汇无关，不管它们说的是华丽、漂亮、OMG还是其他什么。这关乎是谁在评论，以及那个人是给照片点赞还是评论照片——点赞和评论意味着完全不同的事情。你和亲近的人，或者你试图亲近的人评论。而对于亲密的朋友，你几乎必须评论。
It's definitely a social obligation, because you want to let them know, and also let people who are seeing those, that I have a close relationship with this person, so close that I can comment on their pictures, like, this is so cute, or, you look so great here.
这绝对是一种社交义务，因为你想让她们知道，同时也让看到这些评论的人知道，我和这个人有亲密的关系，亲密到我可以在她们的照片下评论，比如，这太可爱了，或者，你在这里看起来棒极了。
Then, of course, when you do post a comment about a picture, there's the whole politics of whether your friend is going to comment back to your comment. And subtle differences in the wording when they comment back could mean something, even though, to an outsider, the words basically look the same. Julia says that she'll comment back, oh my god, I love you so much, to a close friend who compliments a picture of hers. But she says with somebody you don't know so well, it goes differently.
然后，当然，当你确实发了一条关于照片的评论时，你的朋友会不会回评你的评论还有一套政治学。即便在外人看来，这些词看起来基本一样，但她们回评时措辞上的细微差别可能意味着什么。Julia说，她会给赞美她照片的亲密朋友回评“天哪，我太爱你了”。但她说如果是和不那么熟的人，情况就不同了。
If they say, like, oh my god, like, you're so pretty, you say, OMG, but that's you. You know, like-- like you're the pretty one? I feel like that's something that I say to someone who's like-- who I'm not super close with, but I feel like-- like I have to say something back.
如果她们说，比如，天哪，你太漂亮了，你会说，OMG，但那是你。你知道，比如——好像你是那个漂亮的人？我觉得那是会对那种——我不那么亲近，但觉得——觉得我必须回点什么的人说的话。
Especially because we, like, just started high school, so we're meeting a lot of new people. So you would comment on someone's photo who you're not really super close with or that you don't know really well. And it's sort of a statement, like, I want to be friends with you, or I want to get to know you, or like, I think you're cool.
特别是因为我们，比如，刚上高中，所以我们在认识很多新人。所以你会给不太亲近或者不太认识的人的照片评论。这算是一种声明，比如，我想和你做朋友，或者我想了解你，或者，我觉得你很酷。
If someone that you don't know very well commented on your photo, you-- it's sort of like an unspoken agreement that you have to comment back on their photo. Like when you're making new friends, if they comment on your photo, you comment on their photo.
如果不认识的人评论了你的照片，你——这算是一种不成文的约定，你必须回评她们的照片。就像在结交新朋友时，如果她们评论了你的照片，你也会评论她们的照片。
It's like a chain reaction.
这就像连锁反应。
Another thing you don't see if you don't know this language of comments and commenting back-- let's say that you comment on somebody's photo. When they comment back, do they comment to you individually? Or do they group you in with 20 or 30 other people and send just one big group comment back to all of you? That tells you where you stand with the person.
如果你不懂这种评论和回评的语言，你还看不到另一件事——假设你评论了某人的照片。当她们回评时，她们是单独评论你吗？还是把你和另外20或30个人归在一起，发一条统一的大组评论给你们所有人？那告诉你你在那个人心中的地位。
Then there are all those situations where somebody choosing not to comment is a really big deal. Like for example, if you post a picture of yourself with a friend and then the friend does not comment on that picture, that's just cold. That is leaving you dangling. Or if you post a selfie, close friends are expected to chime in with support. When they don't?
还有各种选择不评论的情况，那可是件大事。比如，如果你发了一张你和朋友的合影，然后那个朋友没有评论那张照片，那真是太冷漠了。那是让你悬在那儿。或者如果你发了一张自拍，亲密朋友被期望给予支持。当她们没这么做时？
You definitely feel insecure. Because, like, you expect them to comment, and they don't, and you're like, why?
你绝对会感到不安。因为，比如，你期待她们评论，但她们没有，你会想，为什么？
This isn't even good enough for, like, my best friend.
这甚至不够好，对于我的好朋友来说。
Yeah.
是啊。
Then you're like, oh, wait.
然后你会想，噢，等等。
Like, what if they've seen it  and they're just not liking it on purpose, or like, what if everybody who's seeing it thinks that we're not actually friends because they're not commenting on it. They haven't commented yet. It's been X amount of time and they still haven't liked it.
比如，要是她们看到了，但故意不点赞怎么办，或者，要是所有看到照片的人都觉得我们其实不是朋友，因为她们没有评论。她们还没评论。已经过了X那么久，她们还没点赞。
It's this kind of shallow-- like, why are you not responding to something that I never said you had to respond to in the first place?
这是一种浅薄的——比如，你为什么要对一件我本来就没要求你回复的事情不回复呢？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And tell me about how quickly people have to respond. Like, what's the normal amount of time?
告诉我人们必须回复得有多快。比如，正常的时长是多少？
Within 10 minutes, I think.
十分钟内，我想。
Yeah, usually.
是啊，通常。
People are always on Instagram. Everyone's always on Instagram.
人们总是在Instagram上。每个人总是在Instagram上。
There's definitely a weird psychology to it.
这绝对有一种奇怪的心理。
Yeah.
是啊。
Definitely.
绝对。
It's just sort of the way it is. It's like unspoken rules that everybody knows and follows.
这只是现状。这就像大家都知道并遵守的不成文规则。
But can I ask you, have you gotten caught up in weird mind games where somebody commented or liked or didn't comment or didn't like, and then you're just like, I don't-- what does this-- what does this one means?
但我能问问你，你有没有陷入过奇怪的心理博弈，就是有人评论或点赞，或者没评论或没点赞，然后你就觉得，我不知道——这到底意味着什么？
Yeah. Someone like--
是啊。有人比如——
Ella has an example. I mean, these girls that went to our middle school, they--
Ella有一个例子。我是说，这些去我们初中的女孩，她们——
Yeah, this is not my picture, but someone said, what even? You're perfect. I hate you. Eff you. You suck. And then like someone else, like-- WTF? You're perfect. I hate you.
是啊，这不是我的照片，但有人说，这算什么？你太完美了。我讨厌你。去你的。你真烂。然后像其他人，比如——搞什么鬼？你太完美了。我讨厌你。
Because people-- what they're trying to say is, like, you're so perfect and you're so beautiful that I, like, hate you for it, and I wish I was like you so much that I dislike you for it.
因为人们——她们想表达的是，比如，你太完美了，你太美了，以至于我，比如，因为这个讨厌你，我多希望我能像你一样，以至于我因为这个不喜欢你。
And how do you respond to that? Like, I'm sorry?
那你怎么回应？比如，抱歉？
Because you don't say, like-- you don't say, like, thank you, because it's not really a compliment. You don't really know.
因为你不能说，比如——你不能说，比如，谢谢，因为它不是真正的赞美。你根本不知道。
We've all gotten those comments of-- last year, like, this girl even said it to my face. She was like, you're so pretty, like, I'm going to throw you into the train tracks. Like things that-- like it doesn't even make sense. Like it's--
我们都收到过那种评论——去年，比如，这个女孩甚至当面对我说。她就像，你太漂亮了，比如，我要把你扔到火车轨道上。那种——比如甚至说不通的话。就像它——
Like on my photo right now-- I'm looking at it-- this girl commented, I hate you.
就像我现在拍的照片——我正在看——那个女孩评论说，我讨厌你。
Um, I've also, like, been, like, caught in the situation where someone's like, you're so pretty, and I'm like, oh, thank you. You're really pretty too. And then we've gotten into this whole thing, and I remember, like magical mirrors came up, like potions.
嗯，我也，比如，被困在那种有人说，你太漂亮了，我就说，噢，谢谢。你也很漂亮。然后我们陷入了这种事，我记得，比如魔法镜子出现了，比如药水。
And I was just like, wait, this is way too deep. Like, you must be looking in a mirror then, because you must be talking to yourself, because you're so pretty. She was like, we should switch bodies with, like, a potion. I was like, what?
我就说，等等，这也太深奥了。比如，那你一定是在照镜子，因为你一定是在对自己说话，因为你太漂亮了。她说，我们应该用，比如，药水交换身体。我说，什么？
Ella and Julia and Jane say that usually, they'll get 130 to 150 likes for any selfie they put up, and anywhere between 30 and 50 comments, which is a good response. And overwhelmingly, these comments are these super-positive, you're so pretty, OMG, you're so cute kind. And a lot of it is heartfelt, girls just trying to be good friends to each other. When you see your friend put herself out there, it's nice to tell her she's pretty.
Ella、Julia和Jane说，通常她们发的任何自拍能得到130到150个赞，以及30到50条评论，这算是不错的回应。而且绝大多数情况下，这些评论都是这种超级积极的，你太漂亮了，OMG，你太可爱了那种。很多是发自内心的，女孩们只是想彼此做个好朋友。当你看到你的朋友展示自己时，告诉她她很漂亮是件不错的事。
Can I ask, like, does it work? Because you know, when you're getting over 100 likes and comments and things like that, like, you know, a lot of it is just rote, right? A lot of people are just like, they see a thing, and they just automatically--
我能问问，比如，这管用吗？因为你知道，当你得到超过100个赞和评论之类的时候，比如，你知道，很多只是机械的，对吧？很多人只是，她们看到一个东西，然后她们就自动——
Yeah, you're scrolling through.
是啊，你滑过去了。
It's mindless.
这很盲目。
That's how--
这就是——
It's mindless. And so since it's mindless, does it still work? Does it make you feel good?
这很盲目。既然它很盲目，它还有用吗？它能让你感觉良好吗？
Yes.
有。
Um, actually, if I get a comment from someone I care about, I think it makes me feel good, like it lifts me up.
嗯，事实上，如果我收到我在乎的人的评论，我想这能让我感觉良好，它能振奋我。
A lot of it is just scrolling, too.
很多也只是滑过去。
But a lot of it's just, like, I literally just scroll through my Instagram feed and I just, like, click, like double-tap.
但很多只是，比如，我真的就是滑过我的Instagram推送，然后我就，比如，双击点赞。
Yeah.
是啊。
And like, it doesn't--
而且比如，它并没有——
I like everything on my feed.
我点赞了我推送里的所有东西。
You know, like it just doesn't-- and that's what people are doing to your photo. But, like, it still makes you feel good, because you're getting all these likes.
你知道，这只是没有——人们对你的照片也是这么做的。但是，比如，它仍然让你感觉良好，因为你得到了所有这些赞。
Yeah, but when you think about it, it's so strange. Because you know how superficial it is.
是啊，但当你仔细想时，这太奇怪了。因为你知道它有多肤浅。
It is.
确实。
And yet--
然而——
You know, but yeah.
你知道，但确实。
Yeah.  You know that you're doing it to other people, but--
是啊。你知道你也在对别人做同样的事，但——
And yet it's still--
然而它仍然——
Then other people are doing it to you.
然后别人也对你做同样的事。
And it still feels like something, though.
而且它仍然感觉像回事。
Like, it does make you feel good. You're like, oh, I'm getting all these comments. Like, people like my photo. They think I'm pretty. Like, they're saying that you're pretty. And if someone comes up to you and says you're pretty, like, you're obviously going to be like, thank you, if it makes you feel good. Because it just does. Like, that's like human nature. Like, you're going to feel good.
比如，它确实让你感觉良好。你会想，噢，我得到了这么多评论。比如，人们喜欢我的照片。他们觉得我很漂亮。比如，他们说你很漂亮。如果有人过来对你说你很漂亮，比如，你肯定会说，谢谢，如果它让你感觉良好的话。因为它确实如此。比如，这是人性。比如，你会感觉良好。
This is really not so different from anybody's life on social media. When I tweet something and a friend favorites it, and another friend retweets with a funny comment, that is totally them saying to me, you're so pretty-- just in a more adult kind of way. And it feels nice.
这和任何人在社交媒体上的生活并无不同。当我在推特上发布东西，朋友把它收藏，另一个朋友转发并加上有趣的评论时，那完全就是她们在对我表达，你太漂亮了——只是用一种更成年人的方式。而且这感觉不错。
All three of these girls told me they don't need 50 people telling them that they're pretty all the time. But you know, it's there for the taking. It's like free candy. Why not?
这三个女孩都告诉我，她们并不需要50个人一直告诉她们她们很漂亮。但是你知道，唾手可得。就像免费的糖果。何乐而不为呢？
Do you feel like this is a situation where, like, girls are so judged all the time on how they look, and this is a way to counteract that, by you guys saying to each other, like, you're pretty, you're pretty?
你觉得这是否是一种情况，比如，女孩一直因为她们的外貌被评头论足，而这是你们彼此说，比如，你很漂亮，你很漂亮，来抵消这种情况的一种方式？
Well, no. It just gives more opportunities for people to judge. They're not going to--
嗯，不。这只是给了人们更多评头论足的机会。她们不会——
Yeah, posting a photo of yourself is putting yourself out there.
是啊，发你自己的照片就是把自己展示出来。
They're not going to do it on social media, obviously, because you will see it. But they'll do it behind your back.
她们显然不会在社交媒体上这么做，因为你能看到。但她们会在你背后这么做。
When a girl posts an unflattering selfie, or just a selfie that makes her look uncool, other girls will take screenshots to save the image and gossip about it later. Happens all the time. And so even though they're old hands at posting selfies-- they've been posting since sixth grade-- it can be nervous-making to post one. So they take precautions.
当一个女孩发了一张不好看的自拍，或者只是一张让她看起来不够酷的自拍时，其他女孩会截屏保存图片，然后私下议论。这种事经常发生。所以即便她们是发自拍的老手——她们从六年级就开始发了——发照片还是会让人紧张。所以她们会采取预防措施。
We all ask people before we post it, like send in like a group chat, or like, send to your friends, like, should I post this? Do I look pretty? And they say, like, all the same stuff that they would say in a comment. Like, oh my god, yes, post it. Like, you're so pretty. You're so perfect. So like--
我们发照片前都会问大家，比如发到群聊里，或者，发给你的朋友，比如，我该发这张吗？我看起来漂亮吗？她们会说，比如，所有她们会在评论里说的同样的话。比如，天哪，发吧。比如，你太漂亮了。你太完美了。所以比如——
And so it'd be like you run it by like four or five friends.
所以就像你会拿给四五个朋友看。
Yeah. If I send it to my friends, I'm not nervous about it, because then I have--
是啊。如果我发给朋友看，我就不紧张了，因为那样我就有——
OK.
好的。
Jane looks at her phone. There's a message.
Jane看着她的手机。有一条信息。
Like someone just texted in a giant group chat, go like my photo on Instagram. It just shows that it happens every--
比如有人刚在巨大的群聊里发了，去给我的Instagram照片点赞。这只是说明它无时无刻不在发生——
It happens every second.
它每秒都在发生。
It happens all the time.
它一直都在发生。
Yep. I got it, too.
是的。我也收到了。
Yeah.
是啊。
I have to say, like, oh my god, this is such a job.
我不得不说，比如，天哪，这简直就是一份工作。
Yeah.
是啊。
It's like I'm-- I'm a brand, and I am like--
就像我——我是一个品牌，而我就像——
You're trying to promote yourself.
你是在试图推广你自己。
The brand. I'm the director of the--
品牌。我是这个品牌的导演——
And you're the product.
而你就是产品。
You're definitely trying to promote yourself.
你绝对是在试图推广你自己。
To stay relevant, you have to--
为了保持存在感，你必须——
You have to work hard.
你必须努力工作。
Relevance is a big term right now.
“存在感”现在是个大词。
Are you guys relevant?
你们有存在感吗？
Um, I'm so relevant.
嗯，我很有存在感。
In middle school. In middle school, we were definitely really relevant.
在初中。在初中，我们绝对非常有存在感。
(SARCASTICALLY)  We were so relevant.
(讽刺地) 我们很有存在感。
Because everything was established. But now, in the beginning of high school, you can't really tell who's relevant.
因为一切都已建立。但现在，刚上高中，你真的分辨不出谁有存在感。
Yeah. And what does relevant mean?
是啊。存在感意味着什么？
Relevant means that people care about what you're posting on Instagram. People--
存在感意味着人们关心你在Instagram上发布的内容。人们——
Care about you.
关心你。
--want to know what you're doing. People will open your Snapchat stories.
——想知道你在做什么。人们会打开你的Snapchat故事。
They're only three months into high school, so there is a lot at stake right now.
她们才上高中三个月，所以现在赌注很高。
One of my, like, best friends posts a selfie. Maybe this isn't, like, healthy. But I might go through the comments and see who she's, like, really good friends with, just 'cause we're in high school and there's that sense of jealousy between everyone.
我的一个，比如，最好的朋友发了自拍。也许这不，比如，健康。但我可能会翻看评论，看看她，比如，真正的好朋友是谁，只是因为我们上高中了，每个人之间都有那种嫉妒感。
Do you have people who you're jealous of?
你有嫉妒的人吗？
Yeah.
有。
Yeah. I definitely would. I go through, like, the comments that people see-- like that people say, and like, I see what other people have said to other people.
有。我绝对会有。我会翻看，比如，人们看到的评论——比如人们说的话，然后，比如，我会看到其他人对其他人说了什么。
Yeah.
是啊。
Just to see, like, the whole-- like, the whole social like map.
只是为了看看，比如，整个——比如，整个社交地图。
Looking, mapping out your social world, seeing who's with who, who's hanging out with who, who is best friends with who.
看着，绘制你的社交世界，看看谁和谁在一起，谁和谁待在一起，谁是最好的朋友。
If you didn't have it, like, I feel like I'd be missing so much. And it would just--
如果你没有它，比如，我觉得我会错过太多。这只会——
Because you wouldn't see what other people were saying. A lot goes on.
因为你不会看到别人在说什么。发生了很多事。
Well, no, that's, I feel like, the thing that I'm understanding from this conversation, is like-- it's actually like, you're getting a picture of your entire social world and who's up and who's down and who's close to who, and it's like you're getting a diagram of where everybody stands with everybody else.
嗯，不，那是我，我觉得，从这次谈话中理解到的事，就是——这其实就像是，你在获取你整个社交世界的图片，谁在上位，谁在下位，谁和谁亲近，就像你在获取每个人相对于他人的地位图。
Yeah.
是啊。
Definitely. Definitely.
绝对。绝对。
As it changes in real time, every day, every 10 minutes.
随着它实时改变，每天，每十分钟。
Yeah.
是啊。
Yeah. Everyone can see it.
是啊。每个人都能看到。
It's crazy.
这太疯狂了。
You see these comments. You screenshot them. You show them to your friends at school.
你看到这些评论。你截屏它们。你在学校展示给你的朋友看。
Yeah, I will screenshot things, and be like, look what she said, look what she said. Like even if it's funny.
是啊，我会截屏一些东西，然后说，看她说了什么，看她说了什么。比如即使它很有趣。
I didn't know that these people were close. When did this happen?
我不知道这些人关系这么好。这是什么时候发生的？
This is the main thing they get from Instagram, they say. After all, each of them only post a couple pictures a week. Not that much of their time on Instagram is being told they're pretty. Most of it is this, dissecting and calibrating the minutiae of the social diagram.
这是她们从Instagram上得到的主要东西，她们说。毕竟，她们每人一周只发几张照片。她们在Instagram上花的时间大部分并没有用来被告知她们很漂亮。大部分是这个，剖析和校准社交图谱的琐事。
[MUSIC - "YOU'RE SO BEAUTIFUL" BY JUSSIE SMOLLETT & YAZZ]
[音乐 - "YOU'RE SO BEAUTIFUL" BY JUSSIE SMOLLETT & YAZZ]
Act 2. Mon Ami Ta-Nehisi. Well, our show today is about status updates. And you know, it's weird when a sudden change of status happens to somebody who you're close with. And that's true whether their status goes up or their status goes down.
第二幕。我的朋友Ta-Nehisi。嗯，我们今天的节目是关于状态更新。你知道，当一个你亲近的人突然发生状态改变时，这很奇怪。无论他们的状态上升还是下降，都是如此。
One of our producers, Neil Drumming, is best friends with the writer Ta-Nehisi Coates, who I think a lot of people heard of for the first time a couple years ago when he wrote this article arguing the case for reparations for black Americans. That article was nothing compared to the attention that Ta-Nehisi got when his latest book was published this summer. The book has been on the New York Times Bestseller List ever since. He's been interviewed all over the place. He's been called the next James Baldwin. Ta-Nehisi Coates was suddenly famous and rich, and Neil, our co-worker, definitely was not. He does fine, but, you know. Anyway, it got Neil thinking.
我们的一位制片人，Neil Drumming，是作家Ta-Nehisi Coates的挚友，我想很多人几年前第一次听说他的时候，是他写了那篇为黑人美国人争取赔偿的文章。那篇文章与Ta-Nehisi今年夏天出版新书时受到的关注相比根本不算什么。那本书自那以后一直稳居《纽约时报》畅销书排行榜。他到处接受采访。他被称为下一个James Baldwin。Ta-Nehisi Coates突然变得有名且富有，而Neil，我们的同事，显然并没有。他过得还行，但是，你知道。无论如何，这让Neil开始思考。
Quick warning-- there's some cursing in this story that we bleeped on the radio version of our show. Here on the podcast and the internet, we are unbleeping it. If you're somebody who prefers the bleeped version-- maybe you listen to the show with kids-- you can find it at our website.
快速警告——这个故事里有一些咒骂，我们在节目的广播版本中进行了消音。在这里，在播客和互联网上，我们去掉了消音。如果你是一个倾向于消音版本的人——也许你和孩子们一起听节目——你可以在我们的网站上找到。
One of the weird things about having a famous friend is that even when he's too busy to hang out, he's sort of around all the time. I hadn't seen Ta-Nehisi in a few months. But in the last year or two, it seemed like everyone was reading his work and talking about it-- everyone on the subway, the President of the United States, my ex who texted me out of the blue to see if I could get her into one of his speaking engagements-- everyone.
拥有一个名人朋友的一件怪事是，即使他太忙而没法待在一起，他似乎也一直都在身边。我几个月没见Ta-Nehisi了。但在过去一两年里，似乎每个人都在读他的作品并谈论它——地铁上的每个人，美国总统，发短信突然问我能否带她参加他的一场演讲活动的前女友——每个人。
But by July, I was cat-sitting just 15 blocks from Ta-Nehisi's apartment and he and I still hadn't connected. We tried, but it just didn't work out. I was walking past a newsstand on Broadway, thinking I should try texting him again, that I had so much to tell him. And when I looked up, he was right in front of me, his big-ass disembodied head staring at me from the cover of New York Magazine .
但到了七月，我帮人照看猫，离Ta-Nehisi的公寓只有15个街区，但他和我仍然没有联系上。我们尝试过，但没成功。我走过百老汇的一个报摊，想着我应该再给他发短信，我有很多话要告诉他。当我抬头时，他就在我面前，他那巨大的、脱离躯体的头从《纽约杂志》的封面上盯着我。
By the end of the summer, Ta-Nehisi had turned 40 and moved his family to Paris. He won the MacArthur Genius Award. He was across the ocean, and coworkers were congratulating me for him. It's wild having the world talk so much about someone you know and with whom you share so much history. It's exciting and, oddly, kind of gratifying. I'm happy for him.
夏天结束时，Ta-Nehisi 40岁了，把家人搬到了巴黎。他赢得了麦克阿瑟天才奖。他远在大洋彼岸，同事们因为他的成就向我表示祝贺。有一个你认识并且分享了这么多历史的人被世界如此谈论，这很疯狂。这令人兴奋，且奇怪的是，有点令人满足。我为他高兴。
The thing I'm having trouble with is harder to explain. I know Ta-Nehisi's the same guy-- warm, funny, curious, loves comic books. But he's also a famous writer who lives in Paris, accepts prestigious awards in a tuxedo that he owns, and gets shout-outs from Toni Morrison and Jay Z. He's changing in ways that I'm not. And when people change, they grow apart. And it makes me worry about our friendship.
我难以处理的事情更难解释。我知道Ta-Nehisi还是那个家伙——热情、有趣、好奇，热爱漫画书。但他也是一个住在巴黎、穿着自己拥有的燕尾服接受著名奖项、并得到Toni Morrison和Jay Z的赞美的著名作家。他正在以我不曾有的方式改变。当人们改变时，他们就会疏远。这让我担心我们的友谊。
Like when we're making plans. A couple of months ago, Ta-Nehisi, our other buddy, Rick, and I were supposed to meet for Sunday brunch at our old West Side haunt, The Half King. The Half King is a pub, not a dive, a respectable pub with good service, good beer, and decent food. The morning of the scheduled meeting, he texted to ask if we can meet at the swanky Hotel Marlton instead. His explanation? "I'm becoming that dude."
比如我们在做计划时。几个月前，Ta-Nehisi，我们另一个好友Rick和我，本应在我们西区的旧巢The Half King共进周日早午餐。The Half King是一家酒吧，不是那种肮脏的酒馆，是一家体面的酒吧，有好的服务，好的啤酒和不错的食物。预约见面的那天早上，他发短信问我们是否能在时髦的Hotel Marlton见面。他的解释？“我正在变成那种人。”
Rick was understanding. He joked that since eating in Paris, everything back home must taste like dog food. Ta-Nehisi's response? "It's close."
Rick很理解。他开玩笑说，既然在巴黎吃过饭，家里的一切一定都尝起来像狗粮。Ta-Nehisi的回答？“差不多。”
Sometimes he ends emails with unnecessary French interpolations of everyday phrases. In this country, we have a word for such behavior, and it's the same word in Ta-Nehisi's newly adopted language.
有时他会在电子邮件末尾加上不必要的法语日常短语。在这个国家，我们有一种形容这种行为的词，在Ta-Nehisi新采用的语言里，词是一样的。
Je suis snob.
Je suis snob（我是一个势利鬼）。
That's how you say, "I'm a snob" in French?
那是你用法语说“我是一个势利鬼”的方式吗？
Je suis snob. Snob. I gotta get my accent right. Je suis snob.
Je suis snob。势利鬼。我得把我的口音练对。Je suis snob。
I tease him about becoming a snob, but we've never really talked about it. And so, cautiously and nervously, a couple weeks ago, I asked him if we could. We texted back and forth to set a time when we could sit down. At one point, he suggested that I go through his assistant.
我取笑他变得势利，但我们从没真正谈过。所以，谨慎而紧张地，几周前，我问他我们是否可以。我们来回发短信定了我们坐下来聊的时间。有一次，他建议我通过他的助理。
Ta-Nehisi was tired from a long day of meetings and signing books, so he and I ended up at the bar of the hotel where he was staying. It's a lavish joint with a rooftop pool deck and big, cushioned banquettes in the lounge. We sat up on the mezzanine, overlooking the low-lit bar.
Ta-Nehisi在忙碌的一天会议和签售书后很累，所以我和他最终在他下榻的酒店吧台见面。这是一个奢华的地方，有屋顶游泳池甲板，休息室里有大的、有靠垫的长椅。我们坐在夹层上，俯瞰着低调的吧台。
Is this the best hotel you ever stayed in?
这是你住过的最好的酒店吗？
No.
不。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
This ain't that good of a hotel. But it's perfectly decent. I got a nice room here.
这不是那种很好的酒店。但它相当体面。我在这里有个不错的房间。
Yeah.
是啊。
How's this feel to you? Does this feel like a nice hotel to you?
这感觉如何？这让你感觉是一家好酒店吗？
Ta-Nehisi knew we were here to talk about his snobbery, and he wasted zero time getting into character. He told me a story about the other night when he'd had dinner in the restaurant of this very hotel.
Ta-Nehisi知道我们是来谈论他的势利的，他没浪费任何时间进入角色。他告诉我那天晚上他在这个酒店的餐厅吃饭时的故事。
And I was sitting at the bar. And the food was OK. It's like one of these OK food restaurants. But it was decent. I  was having a good time. And there was a couple like down the bar, and they had ordered this big-ass thing of oysters. It might have been 24 oysters. It was huge.
我当时坐在吧台。食物还可以。这就像那种食物尚可的餐厅之一。但这很体面。我玩得很开心。吧台下有对夫妇，他们点了那种巨大的生蚝。可能有24个生蚝。太大了。
Ta-Nehisi was fine with that. He loves oysters. It was what happened next that offended him.
Ta-Nehisi对那个没问题。他喜欢生蚝。接下来发生的事情让他感到冒犯。
Then the bartender started making drinks, right? And he makes the woman a sangria and the other dude some sweet something, some red, sweet something-or-other that no one should ever drink. And he took it over there, and I was like, you're going to drink sangria and eat oysters? Like, we're doing this now? Like, this is a thing you're going to do? Oh, come on.
然后酒保开始调酒，对吧？他给那个女人调了桑格利亚汽酒，给那个男人调了某种甜甜的饮料，那种没人应该喝的红色甜饮料。他把酒端过去，我当时想，你要喝桑格利亚汽酒吃生蚝？比如，我们现在要这么做吗？比如，这就是你要做的事？噢，算了吧。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Come on. Just order a Hi-C. Get the Capri Sun. Just get the Capri Sun with your oysters.
算了吧。直接点一杯Hi-C好了。拿杯Capri Sun。吃生蚝直接喝Capri Sun算了。
See, this is what I'm talking about.
瞧，这就是我在说的。
I met Ta-Nehisi in the late '90s when we were both working at an alternative weekly newspaper in DC. He was still a student at Howard. I had recently graduated from college.
我是在90年代末认识Ta-Nehisi的，当时我们都在华盛顿的一家另类周报工作。他当时还在霍华德大学读书。我刚大学毕业。
I'm pretty sure neither of us had ever even tasted an oyster back then. Instead, we bonded over hip hop, two-for-one happy hours, the enduring craziness of white people, and wanting to be better writers than the ones in our favorite rap magazine. We bopped around U Street drinking rail liquor and debating the merits of Ghostface, Buckshot, and Brother J.
我很确定我们那时谁都没尝过生蚝。相反，我们通过嘻哈音乐、买一送一的欢乐时光、白人持久的疯狂，以及想成为比我们最喜欢的说唱杂志里更好的作者而产生共鸣。我们在U街到处蹦跶，喝着平价烈酒，争论Ghostface、Buckshot和Brother J的优劣。
We did growing-up stuff, too. We paid rent. We met girls. I remember the day Ta-Nehisi came by the cubicle where I worked to tell me his girlfriend was pregnant. I thought, at 24, his life is over. But soon, I'd have a godson.
我们也做大人的事。我们付房租。我们认识女孩。我还记得Ta-Nehisi来到我工作的隔间告诉我他女朋友怀孕那天。我想，24岁，他的一生结束了。但很快，我就有了一个教子。
We also got pretty serious about writing. Eventually, we both ended up in New York. We got jobs. We got married. Our wives became best friends, as well. We stayed close.
我们对写作也非常认真。最终，我们都来到了纽约。我们有了工作。我们结婚了。我们的妻子也成了最好的朋友。我们一直很亲近。
During all those years, I honestly don't recall fine dining being a big part of our lives, so it's kind of bizarre to hear Ta-Nehisi go on about it now. The guy talks about food with almost as much passion and conviction as he writes scathing critiques of American institutionalized racism.
在那些年里，我真不记得精致餐饮是我们生活的重要部分，所以听到Ta-Nehisi现在一直谈论它真的很奇怪。这家伙谈论食物的热情和信念，几乎和他写尖锐批评美国体制性种族主义的文章一样多。
There's this joint in Chicago called the Girl & the Goat, and they made this asparagus last time I was there, and I think about it. Like I actually think about the vegetables.
芝加哥有一家叫Girl & the Goat的餐厅，上次我在那里，他们做了这种芦笋，我一直在想它。比如我真的在想这些蔬菜。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
I mean, what is this? [LAUGHS] Like sex or something. Like, I think about it. Like god, that was awesome. That was great.
我的意思是，这是什么？[笑] 像性或者什么。比如，我一直在想它。比如上帝，那太棒了。那太好了。
I can't imagine feeling so strongly about vegetables. But we're laughing and drinking adult beverages. This is fun and kind of familiar.
我无法想象对蔬菜有那么强烈的感受。但我们在笑，喝着大人的饮料。这很有趣，也有点熟悉。
You know what this makes me think of?
你知道这让我想到了什么吗？
What?
什么？
The New Year's Eve parties at the place you used to live in--
你以前住的地方的新年派对——
Yeah, yeah, yeah, in Brooklyn.
是啊，是啊，在布鲁克林。
In Brooklyn, yeah. Was it Flatbush?
在布鲁克林，对。是Flatbush吗？
Yeah.
是。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊。
Lefferts Garden.
Lefferts Garden。
Lefferts Garden, which is a completely different place now.
Lefferts Garden，那现在是个完全不同的地方了。
Yeah.
是啊。
But I remember, we used to have those-- remember we'd have those wine parties, and you had to bring a bottle of wine.
但我记得，我们过去常有那些——记得我们过去有那些葡萄酒派对，你必须带一瓶酒。
Yeah, I didn't like that.
是啊，我不喜欢那样。
You remember this? You didn't like that? Why? Why didn't you like that?
你记得吗？你不喜欢？为什么？你为什么不喜欢那样？
That felt status-y to me.
那对我来说感觉有点势利。
Really?
真的吗？
I mean, what are we doing? We're tasting wine and doing-- I mean, what is this?
我的意思是，我们在干什么？我们在品酒，做——我的意思是，这是什么？
But remember, it was like you could bring-- everybody brought kind of cheap wine. People were just--
但记住，就像你可以带——每个人带的都是那种廉价葡萄酒。人们只是——
I mean, [INAUDIBLE] now we're getting to why one wouldn't like it. So we're, like, swapping cheap wine?
我的意思是，[听不清]现在我们要谈为什么有人会不喜欢它了。所以我们，比如，在交换廉价葡萄酒？
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
Like, what are we doing? Are we just-- I think like my read on that was, are we doing this just to say we're the kind of Negroes that eat cheese and drink wine? There was a point where we didn't go, like, really nice places, right?
比如，我们在干什么？我们只是——我觉得我对那个的解读是，我们做这个只是为了说我们是那种吃奶酪喝葡萄酒的黑人？曾经有一点，我们并没有去那种，比如，很高档的地方，对吧？
Yeah, of course not.  I mean, remember--
是啊，当然不。我的意思是，记得——
We used to go to like Lucky Burger.
我们过去常去那种Lucky Burger。
Yeah. And we just--
是啊。我们只是——
Isn't it call Lucky's? Isn't that who it's called?
那不叫Lucky's吗？那不就是它的名字吗？
Yeah, the joint on the--
是啊，那个地方在——
Like 50-something? It's like Hell's Kitchen.
50多街？那就像Hell's Kitchen。
Yeah, we used to go there a lot. We used to get burgers. I mean, what's-- OK, listen. I've known you, what, 19 years? 20 years?
是啊，我们过去常去那儿。我们常吃汉堡。我的意思是，什么——好的，听着。我认识你，多少，19年？20年？
Long time.
很长一段时间。
The majority of that time, we ate wings and burgers.
在那段时间的大部分里，我们吃鸡翅和汉堡。
Right.
对。
Pretty much the majority of that time.
差不多大部分时间都是。
And I did eat that stuff then, and I was fine.
我也吃过那种东西，我挺好的。
Yeah, all the time.
是啊，一直如此。
So what happened?
那怎么了？
This is the reason that you're sitting here, as I'm asking you. OK, well, this is the question.
这就是你坐在这里的原因，因为我在问你。好的，嗯，这就是问题所在。
Well, I made more money, right?
嗯，我赚得更多了，对吧？
Yes.
是。
That's all it is.
仅此而已。
I mean, but-- I mean, how much would you attribute it to that?
我的意思是，但——我的意思是，你会把这归功于多少？
A lot.
很多。
Yeah? Was that ever uncomfortable for you?
是吗？这对你来说曾经不舒服过吗？
The money's uncomfortable.
钱让人不舒服。
Yeah.
是啊。
The money's uncomfortable. Um-- why is the money uncomfortable? Because you have the money, but like, in your mind, you haven't changed. Like you still rock a hoodie.
钱让人不舒服。嗯——为什么钱让人不舒服？因为你有钱，但，在你的头脑里，你没变。比如你仍然穿着连帽衫。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊。
The food is not uncomfortable. The food feels like some bringing to fruition of something that was always there.
食物并不让人不舒服。食物感觉像是某种一直存在的东西的实现。
Mm.
嗯。
Maybe it is bringing to fruition something that was already there. Ta-Nehisi was always a little picky about what kind of beer he drank. And he'd get anxious whenever his hair got a little bushy, even back in the broke DC days when a regular haircut was an extravagance. I started to wonder if maybe there had been snobbiness under the surface all along and I just missed it.
也许它确实实现了某些本来就在那里的东西。Ta-Nehisi一直对喝什么啤酒有点挑剔。而且每当他的头发有点杂乱时，他就会感到焦虑，即使是在华盛顿那些缺钱的日子里，剪个头发也是奢侈。我开始怀疑是不是表面之下一直都有势利，而我只是错过了它。
Still, those are small things, right? He appreciates a nice meal and a trim. So what?
尽管如此，这些都是小事，对吧？他欣赏一顿美餐和一个利落的发型。那又怎样？
Well, I go to a really nice gym.
嗯，我去一家非常好的健身房。
OK. You would go, or you do?
好的。你会去，还是你确实去？
I do.
我确实去。
You do.
你确实去。
I go to a really nice gym.
我去一家非常好的健身房。
How nice is your gym? What gym could be that nice?
你的健身房有多好？什么健身房能有那么好？
I don't want to name the gym. But I can tell you about the gym.
我不想给那个健身房命名。但我可以告诉你关于那个健身房的事。
Is it not, like, a consumer gym?
它不是那种普通的消费级健身房吗？
It is, but it's like really nice.
它是，但它就是非常非常好。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
I mean when I'm in America. Which--
我的意思是我在美国的时候。它——
OK.
好的。
I mean, that was the ultimate snob statement right there. I go to a nice gym in Paris, too.
我的意思是，那简直是终极势利宣言。我在巴黎也去一家很好的健身房。
But they're different gyms, obviously.
但它们显然是不同的健身房。
Yeah, different gyms.
是啊，不同的健身房。
They're not the same brand.
它们不是同一个品牌。
No, no, no. But it's just, like, very nice.
不，不，不。但它就是，比如，非常非常体面。
OK.
好的。
I have personal training.
我有私人教练。
[LAUGHTS
[笑]
Which is snobbery.
那是势利。
Yeah, I can sort of see that.
是啊，我有点能看出来。
I mean, which is-- you know, I mean, I can defend it for you, but it is. It is. It's like privileged to be able to pay for that, right? Like that's some amount of something, you know? I started getting my hair cut every week, too.
我的意思是，也就是——你知道，我的意思是，我可以为你辩护，但它确实是。它就是。这就像能够支付那个费用是一种特权，对吧？比如那是一定程度上的某些东西，你知道吗？我开始每周剪一次头发，也是。
Well, that was something you always wanted, though.
嗯，那一直是你想要的，虽然。
Oh, I did always want that.
噢，我确实一直想要那个。
You used to talk about that a lot.
你过去常谈论那个。
Yeah, I always wanted that.
是啊，我一直想要那个。
You used--
你过去——
But is that a kind of snobbery?
但这是一种势利吗？
I don't know.
我不知道。
I think I'm a snob, but I don't think I'm bougie.
我觉得我是一个势利鬼，但我不觉得我很虚荣（bougie）。
OK. That's like-- I feel like for This American Life , you're going to have to explain that.
好的。那就像——我觉得对于《美国生活》，你必须解释一下。
OK, what bougie means?
好的，bougie是什么意思？
Yeah. You're gonna have to--
是啊。你必须——
So "bougie" is a term that black people use-- and I guess white people have used it now, 'cause I see white people using it-- which I think people think is interchangeable with "snob." But I actually don't think.
所以“bougie”是一个黑人使用的词——我猜白人现在也用了，因为我看到白人在用——我认为人们觉得它和“势利”可以互换。但我其实不这么认为。
OK.
好的。
OK. So like [INAUDIBLE] say, you know, a bougie's a person who's snob, looks down. But see, bougie people want to be part of a crowd.
好的。所以比如[听不清]说，你知道，一个bougie的人是一个势利鬼，瞧不起人。但你看，bougie的人想成为人群的一部分。
OK.
好的。
Like, they want to be part of the right crowd. So for instance, I don't want to put my son in some exclusive club or something, literally like some sort of societal something or other. Do you know what I mean?
比如，他们想成为正确人群的一部分。所以举个例子，我不想把我儿子送进什么排外的俱乐部或者什么的，字面意义上那种社会层面的什么什么。你知道我的意思吗？
So bougie is a status thing. It's about--
所以bougie是一种地位的东西。它是关于——
Yeah, I don't care about any of that. I actually don't care about my status.
是啊，我不在乎那些。我其实不在乎我的地位。
OK. All right, all right.
好的。没问题，没问题。
Yeah, I don't go to a nice gym so that I can then tell you I go to a nice gym. I don't have any concern about being seen with the right people. You know what I'm saying? Like, I don't have that. I don't need to be at the right parties.
是啊，我不是为了能告诉别人我去一家好的健身房才去好的健身房。我一点都不担心和正确的人在一起。你知道我在说什么吗？比如，我没有那个。我不需要参加正确的派对。
OK.
好的。
Like, I don't need any of that.
比如，我不需要那些。
OK.
好的。
And I don't really look down on people who aren't, like, around the right people. Like,  I don't have that. That's bougie.
而且我真的不会瞧不起那些不，比如，没和正确的人在一起的人。比如，我没有那种心态。那是bougie。
OK.
好的。
Snobbery, to me, is about, like, things. [LAUGHS] And not about people at all. In fact, it's much worse than bougie. 'Cause it's--
对我来说，势利是关于，比如，东西。[笑] 而不是关于人。事实上，它比bougie糟多了。因为它是——
Maybe Ta-Nehisi doesn't care about being with the right people. I've seen him blow off invitations to hang out with TV stars and dodge the attention of world-famous rappers. But he does move in elite circles these days, hanging out with Michael Chabon, collaborating with David Simon, lunches with David Remnick. For the record, that's a Pulitzer Prize-winning author, the creator of The Wire , and the editor of The New Yorker .
也许Ta-Nehisi不在乎和正确的人在一起。我见过他推掉和电视明星待在一起的邀请，也避开过世界级说唱歌手的关注。但他这些天确实在精英圈子里游走，和Michael Chabon待在一起，和David Simon合作，和David Remnick共进午餐。记录一下，那是获得普利策奖的作家，《火线》的创作者，以及《纽约客》的编辑。
Me, I work at home. I cut my own hair. And I definitely prefer burgers to oysters. And that's cool. This isn't about envy for me. I don't feel jealous. I've thought about it, and it's not that.
至于我，我在家工作。我自己剪头发。而且我绝对更喜欢汉堡而不是生蚝。那很酷。这对我来说不是关于嫉妒。我不觉得嫉妒。我想过了，并不是那种。
But it does feel weird, and I'm not sure why. And I just kind of wanted to understand that.
但这确实感觉很奇怪，我不确定为什么。我只是有点想了解一下。
I guess in some ways, I have, like, fretted that, like, maybe we were losing pace with each other. Like I was kind of like--
我猜在某些方面，我，比如，一直担心，比如，也许我们在互相失去步伐。比如我当时有点——
(SHOCKED)  For food?
(震惊) 为食物？
No. I mean-- but the food goes with a lot of other things. It's like, you know, it's not just the food. But it's like, thinking that-- you know, it's like maybe like lifestyle stuff.
不。我的意思——但食物伴随着很多其他事情。这就像，你知道，不仅仅是食物。但它就像，想着——你知道，这就像也许是 lifestyle（生活方式）的东西。
What else was I doing?
我还做了什么？
I don't know, like--
我不知道，比如——
Going to France?
去法国？
Staying at Chabon's house, stuff like that, just having these experiences that seem like--
待在Chabon的家里，类似的事情，只是拥有这些看起来像——
I mean, these are people, but it just-- I don't think I've changed, actually. So I just want-- like, how does this go? I stay at Chabon's house, and then I do what?
我的意思是，这些是人，但它只是——我不觉得我变了，其实。所以我只是想——比如，这怎么进行？我待在Chabon的家里，然后我做什么？
Nothing. That-- it's just--
什么都不做。那——它只是——
[LAUGHS] Like who do I come back as [INAUDIBLE]?
[笑] 比如我回来变成了谁[听不清]？
But here-- OK, but see-- I think that--
但在这里——好的，但是看——我觉得——
What happens?
发生什么了？
The embarrassing part about it is that it actually has more to do with, like, me. I don't know if I can communicate or, like, relate anymore.
尴尬的部分在于它其实更多地和，比如，我有关。我不知道我是否还能交流，或者，比如，产生共鸣。
But we never had that problem, did we?
但我们从没遇到过那种问题，对吧？
No, we never did. You just--
不，我们从没。你只是——
How much of that is the divorce, though?
离婚占了多少因素呢？
I don't know. Why-- explain. How do you mean?
我不知道。为什么——解释一下。你是什么意思？
Well, you had this huge rupture in your life, right?
嗯，你的生活发生了这种巨大的破裂，对吧？
Yeah.
是啊。
And your lifestyle changed. I mean, your lifestyle changes.
而且你的生活方式改变了。我的意思是，你的生活方式改变了。
That's true.
那确实是真的。
I mean, you're out dating and doing, you know, whatever you're doing.
我的意思是，你在外面约会，做，你知道，无论你在做什么。
Yeah.
是啊。
Things did get a little crazy for me after my divorce a couple years ago, more so than I'd like to admit. But it hadn't occurred to me that he would think I was the one who had changed, that that might be the reason for the distance between us. And after the divorce, Ta-Nehisi did keep reaching out. He'd call to talk about writing, or to get feedback on what he was working on, which was always kind of confusing to me.
几年前我离婚后，事情对我来说确实有点疯狂，比我愿意承认的要疯狂得多。但我没想到他会以为是我改变了，那可能是我们之间产生距离的原因。离婚后，Ta-Nehisi确实一直在联系。他会打电话来谈论写作，或者为他正在做的工作寻求反馈，这对我来说总是有点困惑。
I have to admit, I'm kind of like, well, you could also call David Simon, or any of these people who you have on speed dial--
我不得不承认，我有点像，嗯，你也可以打电话给David Simon，或者任何你在快速拨号名单里的这些人——
Yeah, but my friends haven't really changed, you know that? Why would I call them? First of all, they're not smarter than you. I mean, I'm not trying to flatter-- like there's no evidence that they're smarter than you. Like the fact that they've gotten more, or had more accolades, it doesn't mean they're smarter than you.
是啊，但我的朋友们没真正变，你知道吗？我为什么要给他们打？首先，他们没你聪明。我的意思是，我不是在恭维——比如没有证据表明他们比你聪明。比如他们获得了更多，或者拥有了更多奖项，并不意味着他们比你聪明。
In anyone else's perception in the world, right, they are. You know what I'm saying? They are. They would be. Those people would be. Those are--
在世界上任何人的认知里，对吧，他们是。你知道我在说什么吗？他们是。他们会是的。那些人会是的。那些是——
But I don't think-- I haven't talked to them. Out of respect for them, I don't think they think they are. But I don't think that's their perception of themselves.
但我没觉得——我没和他们谈过。出于对他们的尊重，我不认为他们觉得他们是。但我认为这不是他们对自己认知的理解。
And I'm gonna-- I am sensitive to this right now, like right now, because of what's going on. People put shit on you, man. They put shit on you.
而且我会——我现在对这个很敏感，就是现在，因为正在发生的事情。人们把狗屎放在你身上，伙计。他们把狗屎放在你身上。
What do you mean?
什么意思？
Well, the world talks about you in a certain way, and it becomes very easy to confuse what everyone says about you with how you actually think of yourself.
嗯，世界以某种方式谈论你，这很容易让你把你所说的所有人对你的评价和你实际对自己的评价搞混。
M.. I think it was wanting to feel like we're still on the same level, which has not-- it's not an intellectual thing as much as it is, like-- it is an intellectual thing because our friendship is intellectual.
嗯。我想这是想感觉到我们还在同一个水平上，这并不是智力上的东西，更多的是，比如——这确实是智力上的东西，因为我们的友谊是建立在智力基础上的。
Right, right, right.
对，对，对。
That friendship is heartfelt and true, but also, like, the way we come up is ideas. Like you and I have a kinship of ideas, you, me, and Rick.
那段友谊是发自内心的，是真实的，但也像，我们产生共鸣的方式是理念。比如你、我和Rick有理念上的亲缘关系。
Right.
对。
And we've always had that. And so when I feel-- so like having an intellectual disparity makes that friendship feel tenuous to me. I think I was afraid to say that to you, because I was afraid that would actually upset the friendship.
我们一直有那个。所以当我感觉到——比如拥有智力上的差异会让那段友谊对我来说感觉脆弱。我想我当时害怕对你说那个，因为我怕那会真正破坏那段友谊。
I don't know, man. You know, like the other part of that is it's just not-- I'm happy to be at The Atlantic . I'm happy that this book got published. I gotta tell you, all the other shit don't make me very happy.
我不知道，伙计。你知道，比如那部分的另一面是它根本不是——我很高兴能在《大西洋》工作。我很高兴这本书出版了。我不得不告诉你，所有其他那些狗屎并没有让我很开心。
OK, now this is probably not for the tape. But this is some shit I thought of, and it really hit me this weekend, or last weekend. Because I realized that I was doing a lot of intellectual gymnastics in my head about how I felt about us, and I realized I've seen you a bunch of times since then, and you're going through something, and I'm not asking you if you're OK. And I haven't asked you, like, if you're--
好的，现在这可能不是录音的内容。但这是我想到的一些狗屎，它真的在这周末，或者上周末触动了我。因为我意识到我的头脑里在做很多关于我们之间感觉如何的智力体操，我意识到从那时起我见你很多次了，你正经历一些事情，而我没问你是否还好。而且我还没问过你，比如，如果你是——
No, I'm not OK. [LAUGHS]
不，我不好了。[笑]
And that's the thing that hit me, literally, like this weekend. I was like, wait a minute. I've been really selfish about this.
那就是真正触动我的事情，字面意思，就像这个周末。我想，等一下。我在这件事上一直非常自私。
No, it's all right. No, I'm not. I mean, I don't want to-- look at this shit. I was in Kalamazoo, Michigan. Look at this shit.
不，没关系。不，我不。我的意思是，我不想——看这些狗屎。我在密歇根州的卡拉马祖。看这些狗屎。
OK, so for the tape, just for the record, I'm looking at a billboard of Ta-Nehisi Coates-- that's a young pic. You're, like, 12 in that picture.
好的，所以为了录音，记录在案，我正在看一张Ta-Nehisi Coates的广告牌——那是张年轻时的照片。你在那张照片里，比如，12岁。
No, it was like-- they took it when I first got to The Atlantic .
不，它是像——他们在我刚到《大西洋》时拍的。
Oh, OK. So this is a picture--
噢，好的。所以这是一张——
Maybe I'm 33.
也许我33岁。
--of a young Ta-Nehisi Coates hanging over a freeway in Kalamazoo, Michigan. "Ta-Nehisi Coates, November 3, Miller Auditorium." Holy shit.
——年轻的Ta-Nehisi Coates挂在密歇根州卡拉马祖的高速公路上。“Ta-Nehisi Coates，11月3日，米勒礼堂。”该死。
She must want to know, is she seeing that?
她一定想知道，她看到了那个吗？
OK, so what's the good in that? What's the good in that and what's the bad in that?
好的，那有什么好处？那有什么好处和坏处？
I mean, the good in that is that, um-- the message is going to a lot of people. Like, what you write is clearly, on some level, being received by a lot of people. The bad in that is my face.
我的意思是，那里的好处是，嗯——信息传达给了很多人。比如，你写的东西显然在某种程度上被很多人接收到了。那里的坏处是我的脸。
Ta-Nehisi doesn't like having his face on a billboard. He doesn't like being recognized in the street. I know the guy. I don't have many people in my life I know as well as him. He's never wanted to be famous or celebrated. In that way, he's right. He hasn't changed.
Ta-Nehisi不喜欢把他的脸放在广告牌上。他不喜欢在街上被认出来。我认识这家伙。我的生活里没有多少人像他这么熟。他从没想过要出名或者被庆祝。在这方面，他是对的。他没变。
He and I talked for two more hours, and it felt like it always has. But we've lost a lot of the other stuff, the stuff that makes most friendships work. We don't go to the same parties or eat in the same restaurants. We don't share as many friends. He's raising a kid, and I just quit Tinder. We don't even live in the same country. Without all of that, what we have left feels more delicate.
他和我就聊了两个小时，感觉就像以往一样。但我们失去了很多其他东西，那些让大多数友谊维持的东西。我们不去同一个派对，也不在同一家餐厅吃饭。我们分享的朋友没那么多了。他在养个孩子，而我刚退出了Tinder。我们甚至不在同一个国家。没有那些，我们剩下的东西感觉更脆弱。
So now I have another worry. I worry that the conversation that I just forced us to have, where I made such a big deal out of our differences, has in some way screwed with that friendship even more.
所以现在我有了另一个担忧。我担心我刚刚强迫我们进行的对话，我把我们的差异看得太重，在某种程度上让那段友谊变得更加糟糕。
I went to see Ta-Nehisi speak at the Schomburg Center in Harlem. It was the first time I'd been to one of his public appearances in a very long time. The line outside was around the corner. When the audience was let in, they spilled over into a different room. 9,000 people had RSVP'd for 350 seats. Ta-Nehisi was engaging and provocative on stage. I felt proud. He was nice on the mic, and the crowd loved him.
我去哈莱姆的Schomburg中心看Ta-Nehisi演讲。这是我很长一段时间以来第一次去他的公开亮相。外面的队伍绕过了拐角。当听众被放进去时，他们溢到了另一个房间。9000人给350个座位回复了RSVP。Ta-Nehisi在舞台上极具吸引力和煽动性。我感到骄傲。他在麦克风前表现得很好，人群爱他。
It's very, very important to me that I remember to go back to that and not enroll myself in my own dream.
记住回到那一点，而不是让自己进入自己的梦境，这对我来说非常非常重要。
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和掌声]
I've been thinking about it. I've been thinking about it.
我一直在想它。我一直在想它。
Afterwards, I waited outside the green room with Ta-Nehisi's wife and a handful of his friends, some from his Howard days. Celebrities like Common and Usher were there as well, pressing to get backstage to meet him. I chatted with his son, Samori, my godson, about how he was liking Paris. He was having girl trouble. Like his dad used to, I joked.
事后，我在绿屋外面等着Ta-Nehisi的妻子和他的一些朋友，其中一些是他霍华德大学时期的。Common和Usher这样的名人也在那里，挤着要到后台去见他。我和他的儿子Samori聊天，我的教子，关于他是如何喜欢巴黎的。他有女孩方面的麻烦。就像他爸爸过去那样，我开玩笑说。
We had dinner reservations at Red Rooster in Harlem, but it was live jazz night and they wanted us to pay to be quiet. Ta-Nehisi wasn't having it. Later he'd say the joint was bougie. So we went down the street to Sylvia's and had a great time.
我们在哈莱姆的Red Rooster预订了晚餐，但那是现场爵士之夜，他们想让我们花钱买安静。Ta-Nehisi没理会那套。后来他说那个地方很虚荣（bougie）。所以我们去了街下的Sylvia's，玩得很开心。
We gotta go, babe.
我们得走了，宝贝。
Bye, guys.
再见，伙计们。
All right, talk to you.
好的，回头聊。
I'm not gonna see you for--
我不打算见你，直到——
Hey, man, thanks for hanging, man.
嘿，哥们，谢谢你出来玩，哥们。
Of course, man.
当然，哥们。
You had a good time?
你玩得开心吗？
Yeah, of course, man.
是啊，当然，哥们。
OK. All right, cool. OK.
好的。好的，酷。好的。
All right, let me give you a quick hug. It was good seeing you.
好的，让我给你一个快速的拥抱。很高兴见到你。
[INAUDIBLE].
[听不清]。
Oh, you are.
噢，你是。
Catch you soon, brother.
回头见，兄弟。
All right, man. Let me know when you get back.
好的，哥们。等你回来告诉我。
Ta-Nehisi climbed into a black SUV, went back to his hotel, and hopped on a plane the next morning. I stood on the street, fumbling with my recorder. For some reason, it took me a really long time to figure out how to turn it off. Then I headed home to Brooklyn. I don't know what's going to happen next.
Ta-Nehisi爬进了一辆黑色SUV，回到了酒店，第二天早上跳上一架飞机。我站在街上，笨拙地操作着录音机。由于某种原因，我花了很长时间才弄清楚怎么关掉它。然后我回到布鲁克林的家。我不知道接下来会发生什么。
Neil Drumming is one of the producers of our show. Coming up, an entire town gets a status update, and they are not super stoked about it. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
Neil Drumming是我们节目的制片人之一。接下来，整个城镇进行了一次状态更新，他们对它并不太感冒。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on the program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program-- "Status Update."
这里是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。每周节目，当然，我们选择一个主题，带给你们关于该主题的各种故事。今天的节目——“状态更新”。
Today's program is about people whose position in the world changes, in one way or another, and how they deal with it. So far on our show, we've had a literal status update, the social media kind. We've heard what it sounds like inside a friendship where there's been a major shift in status.
今天的节目是关于那些在世界上地位以某种方式发生改变的人，以及他们如何处理它。到目前为止，我们已经有了一次字面意义上的状态更新，那种社交媒体类的。我们听到了当一段友谊中的地位发生了重大转变时，听起来是什么样的。
And now we've arrived at Act Three of our show. Act Three, There Owes the Neighborhood. In this act, we're going to look at an entire city getting a status update. And the man who gave this city the news about itself was named Paul Kiel. Before the city knew, Paul Kiel knew. And before Paul Kiel knew, nobody knew.
现在我们到了节目的第三幕。第三幕，邻里皆欠债。在这一幕中，我们将看到一个城市进行了一次状态更新。而那个向这个城市通报自身新闻的人名叫Paul Kiel。在城市知道之前，Paul Kiel知道。而在Paul Kiel知道之前，没有人知道。
Here's what happened. Paul's an investigative reporter with ProPublica. And he discovered that over the last 15 years, this new kind of debt collector has become more prevalent. These are companies that go after people who owe on their credit cards, or car loans, or hospital bills, or whatever.
发生了什么事。Paul是ProPublica的调查记者。他发现，在过去的15年里，这种新的债务催收员变得更加普遍。这些公司专门针对那些信用卡、汽车贷款、医院账单等欠债的人。
And these companies, what they do is they garnish people's wages. They garnish their wages. They take the money right out of their paychecks. Sometimes they go straight into their bank accounts and take the money.
而这些公司，他们所做的是扣押人们的工资。他们扣押人们的工资。他们直接从人们的工资支票中扣钱。有时他们直接进入人们的银行账户拿钱。
They got this power by taking these people to court. Way more consumers who owe money are being taken to court. These companies sue those consumers, which used to be rare. They sue, and they win. And because they win, they get the power to garnish these wages.
他们通过将这些人告上法庭获得了这种权力。远比过去更多的欠债消费者被告上法庭。这些公司起诉那些消费者，这在过去是很罕见的。他们起诉，并且他们赢了。因为他们赢了，他们就获得了扣押这些工资的权力。
OK, so figuring out that part was just the beginning. Chana Joffe-Walt talked to Paul Kiel.
好的，所以弄清楚那一部分只是开始。Chana Joffe-Walt和Paul Kiel聊了聊。
It was a struggle to get numbers on wage garnishing. How many people? How much money? Where were those people? Paul Kiel loves this kind of thing. He's an even-measured guy who enjoys the grunt work of tracking down which file cabinet in which municipal building of which small town has the information he needs.
获取工资扣押的数据是一场斗争。多少人？多少钱？这些人都在哪？Paul Kiel喜欢这种事情。他是一个温和的人，喜欢追踪在哪个小镇的市政大楼的哪个文件柜里有他需要的信息这种苦差事。
Eventually, Paul and his colleague Annie Waldman had managed to track down the names and addresses of every single person who'd been sued for not paying their debts in three cities-- Newark, Chicago, and St. Louis. They put all that information into the computer, and then Paul looked at what they had.
最终，Paul和他的同事Annie Waldman设法追踪到了三个城市——纽瓦克、芝加哥和圣路易斯——每一个被起诉不还债的人的姓名和地址。他们把所有那些信息放进计算机，然后Paul看了看他们拥有的东西。
Without doing a fancy analysis, if we sorted our neighborhoods so that the ones that had the most lawsuits were at the top, it was all black neighborhoods.
如果不做花哨的分析，如果我们把我们的社区排序，让诉讼最多的那些排在最上面，它们全是黑人社区。
In Newark, Chicago--
在纽瓦克、芝加哥——
In Newark and Chicago and in St. Louis.
在纽瓦克和芝加哥以及圣路易斯。
All of them.
全部。
So there were way more lawsuits in black neighborhoods than in white neighborhoods.
所以黑人社区的诉讼远多于白人社区。
Yes. That was clear no matter how you looked at it. In neighborhoods that had the same income level, the same household income, on average, we were finding twice as many lawsuits in the mostly black neighborhoods. And then it was a real question of why.
是。无论你怎么看，这一点都很清楚。在收入水平相同、家庭收入相同的社区，平均而言，我们在主要是黑人的社区发现的诉讼是两倍。然后这就是一个为什么的真正问题。
Paul knew people would look at this and think what I thought. This is just discrimination-- companies targeting black people and black neighborhoods.
Paul知道人们看到这个会想我所想的。这只是歧视——针对黑人和黑人社区的公司。
Did you think this was just racism?
你认为这只是种族主义吗？
No, I didn't. No, I didn't jump to that conclusion, just because I know how it's such a large and impersonal system. You know, debt-buying companies and other banks might never meet their customers. You're literally a name on a spreadsheet to these companies. So it was immediately like a puzzle that we needed to find an answer to.
不，我不认为。不，我没有草率下那个结论，只是因为我知道它是多么庞大且非个人的系统。你知道，买债公司和其他银行可能永远见不到他们的客户。对这些公司来说，你字面上只是电子表格上的一个名字。所以它立刻就像一个我们需要找到答案的谜题。
Paul's first clue to the answer came when he went to a place called Jennings, Missouri. Jennings is a suburb of St. Louis, home to an astonishing amount of wage garnishing. And Jennings is where Paul met Cori Winfield.
Paul找到答案的第一个线索来自他去一个叫Jennings，密苏里州的地方。Jennings是圣路易斯的一个郊区，也是令人吃惊的工资扣押量的发源地。Jennings就是Paul遇到Cori Winfield的地方。
Oh my god. OK, so like an example.
我的天。好的，所以比如一个例子。
Cori was the first person to show Paul her paycheck. She works for a brokerage services firm in St. Louis.
Cori是第一个给Paul看她工资支票的人。她在圣路易斯的一家经纪服务公司工作。
I just got paid Friday. And my check is usually, gross, around $1,100, $1,200, something like that. But when I got my-- when I got paid Friday, I had $691 on my check. My rent is $750.
我周五刚发工资。我的支票通常，税前，大约1100美元、1200美元，诸如此类。但当我收到我的——当我周五发工资时，我支票上只有691美元。我的房租是750美元。
Here's how this happened. Cori was married-- four kids and a neat brick bungalow under a shady tree with a patch of grass just large enough to be called a lawn. She had a mortgage on that brick bungalow, and she had a van she bought in 2009 for $8,000. The loan on that van is the one that got her in trouble. That's the loan Cori's now paying for out of her paycheck.
这就是事情发生的过程。Cori曾结过婚——四个孩子，一栋林荫下整洁的砖瓦平房，草皮够大到被称为草坪。那栋砖瓦平房有抵押贷款，她还有一辆她在2009年花8000美元买的货车。那辆货车的贷款就是让她陷入麻烦的贷款。那就是Cori现在从工资里支付的贷款。
So the lender in this case was Midwest Acceptance, which is like a St. Louis-based, mostly subprime auto loan company.
所以这个案件的贷款方是Midwest Acceptance，它就像一家总部位于圣路易斯的，主要是次贷性质的汽车贷款公司。
Midwest Acceptance.
Midwest Acceptance。
Midwest Acceptance, yes.
Midwest Acceptance，是的。
Subprime meaning high interest rate. Really high-- 30%. In 2010, Cori stopped paying the car loan. And she stopped paying it for a bunch of reasons. Her husband left, so she had to carry the car loan and the mortgage on the brick bungalow with the small patch of grass all by herself.
次贷意味着高利率。真的很高——30%。2010年，Cori停止支付汽车贷款。她停止支付的原因有很多。她丈夫离开了，所以她必须独自承担那辆货车的贷款和有小片草坪的砖瓦平房的抵押贷款。
Also, Cori's stepfather died. She got a new boyfriend. Her boyfriend was killed. She took a brief absence from work. One of her dogs died. She describes herself at this time as very distracted.
还有，Cori的继父去世了。她交了一个新男朋友。她的男朋友被杀了。她从工作中请了一段短暂的假。她的一只狗死了。她描述那时的自己非常心烦意乱。
So I wasn't keeping up with court dates. I wasn't paying attention to the notices they were sending in the mail.
所以我没跟上出庭日期。我没注意他们寄到邮件里的通知。
And they were sending lots of notices. They were calling, too.
而且他们寄了很多通知。他们也打了电话。
Midwest Acceptance. And they'd be like, um, when are you going to be in to make a payment? I'll be in, um, on my next pay period.
Midwest Acceptance。他们就像，嗯，你打算什么时候来付款？我说，嗯，我下次发薪期来。
Well, we need you to come in before then.  You're going to have to do something. You don't got a grandma you can call? You don't got a mama you can call? Or little stuff like that.
好吧，我们需要你在那之前过来。你得做点什么。你没个奶奶可以打给吗？你没个妈妈可以打给吗？或者诸如此类的小事。
The grandma. This turned out to be Paul's answer. Cori did have a grandma she often called, but her grandma was already trying to help Cori save her house. And she was helping Cori with car rides once Midwest repo'd Cori's car.
那个奶奶。这成了Paul答案。Cori确实有个奶奶她经常打给，但她奶奶已经在努力帮Cori保住房子了。而且在Midwest收回Cori的车后，她一直在帮Cori处理搭车事宜。
Her grandma was also helping Cori's mom and her uncle. And she was doing all that on a pension. Cori's grandma was the only person she'd ever been able to call in this kind of situation.
她奶奶也在帮Cori的妈妈和叔叔。而且她是用养老金做这一切。Cori的奶奶是她在这种情况下唯一能打给的人。
If you ask people, could you borrow $3,000 from a friend or family member in an emergency? White people are much more likely to say yes. Poor whites, a white person living in abject poverty, has roughly the same ability to borrow $3,000 in an emergency as a middle-class black person. That's according to the largest national survey of consumer finance. If you compare Jennings, where Cori was, to white towns where people make the same amount of money?
如果你问人们，在紧急情况下你能从朋友或家人那里借到3000美元吗？白人更有可能说是。贫穷的白人，一个生活在赤贫中的白人，在紧急情况下借到3000美元的能力，大约和一个中产阶级黑人相同。这是根据最大规模的全国消费者金融调查得出的。如果你把Cori所在的Jennings和收入水平相同的白人城镇相比？
In that income bracket, whites, on average, have five times the wealth as black households.
在那个收入区间，平均而言，白人的财富是黑人家庭的五倍。
So wealth meaning home ownership and savings and investments and all of that stuff?
所以财富是指房产所有权、储蓄、投资以及所有那些东西？
It's like everything you have that you could turn into money, whether it be equity in your home, or your car, or whatever. It was right in front of me. So if people in the same income level have five times the wealth, it seems very credible that that would have a major impact on whether they're able to deal with a debt. That, to me, is-- the answer's right there.
就像你拥有的所有可以变现的东西，无论是你的房产净值，还是你的车，或者其他什么。它就在我面前。所以如果收入水平相同的人拥有五倍的财富，似乎非常可信的是，那会对他们是否有能力处理债务产生重大影响。那，对我来说是——答案就在那儿。
And you were asking me, like, well, is this because of discrimination? And we don't have direct evidence that these suits are happening more often in black communities because of discrimination, but the racial wealth gap is definitely because of discrimination.
而你问我，比如，嗯，这是因为歧视吗？我们没有直接证据表明在黑人社区这些诉讼更频繁地发生是因为歧视，但种族财富差距绝对是因为歧视。
So why do we have a racial wealth gap? Because we had centuries of racist public policy. And even in the 20th century, blacks were prevented from buying homes in certain areas, and there were a lot of policies that helped whites build wealth at the same time they were preventing blacks from doing that. So it was-- it's a wealth gap that was fostered by racist policy, which we really haven't recovered from. Because wealth takes time to build over generations.
所以为什么会有种族财富差距？因为我们有几个世纪的种族主义公共政策。即使在20世纪，黑人也被阻止在特定地区买房，有很多政策帮助白人建立财富的同时，阻止黑人做同样的事。所以它——这是一种由种族主义政策培育的财富差距，我们真的还没从中恢复过来。因为财富需要几代人的时间去建立。
Paul knew all of this before he started looking into wage garnishing. He knew this history, from Jim Crow laws all the way up through restrictive covenants in housing. He knew the data. But it wasn't until Cori that he considered it the answer to his puzzle.
Paul在开始调查工资扣押之前就知道所有这些。他知道这段历史，从吉姆·克劳法案一直到住房中的限制性契约。他知道数据。但直到遇到Cori，他才认为这是他谜题的答案。
Which is interesting. The wealth gap is such a basic old fact about America that it's become a saggy, meaningless phrase. "The widening wealth gap." "How to narrow the wealth gap."
这很有趣。财富差距是美国一个非常基础的老事实，以至于它成了一个松垮、毫无意义的词组。“不断扩大的财富差距。”“如何缩小财富差距。”
It's kind of an abstract concept.
这是一种抽象的概念。
And this is what it looks like.
而这就是它看起来的样子。
Right. Yeah. And so this is one good illustration of that.
对。是啊。所以这是那点很好的例证。
So I'm standing on a street. Standing on a street in the middle of Jennings, not too far from the high school.
所以我站在街上。站在Jennings中间的一条街上，离高中不远。
Paul found himself in a peculiar situation. He had a detailed spreadsheet, with addresses, listing everyone who hasn't paid their debts, how much they owed, and for what. Basically he had a map of the neighborhood he was standing in that included intimate details about people's financial lives.
Paul发现自己处于一种奇特的处境。他有一份详细的电子表格，有地址，列出了所有没还债的人，他们欠多少钱，为了什么。基本上他拥有他所站社区的一张地图，包含了人们财务生活的亲密细节。
About half the homes on this block have had a lawsuit against them.
这条街上大约一半的房子都受到过诉讼。
On some blocks, it was every other house. Sometimes there were a few in just one house. It was a social map of the neighborhood that was the opposite of the carefully curated status updates you usually see.
在某些街区，那是隔壁房子。有时仅仅一所房子里就有几起。这是一个社区的社交地图，和你平时看到的精心策划的状态更新相反。
What Paul could see was something real and messy-- what was going on with people's finances. And he wondered, if you live here, do you just know about this? Or do you actually need to see the map to picture it?
Paul能看到的是真实的、凌乱的东西——人们的财务状况如何。他感到好奇，如果你住在这里，你难道不知道吗？还是你真的需要看到那张地图才能想象它？
There's a street-- there's a house at the end here.
有一条街——这里尽头有一所房子。
How did you get my name?
你是怎么得到我的名字的？
Well, it was court records.
嗯，那是法庭记录。
OK.
好的。
So--
所以——
They are public.
它们是公开的。
They are public, yeah. And--
它们是公开的，是啊。而且——
This woman, Devorah, had been sued for money she owed the Metropolitan Sewer District. But she did not know that they'd sued her next door neighbor, too. Up the street and around the corner, Paul finds a block party going on. He sees a guy barbecuing in front of his house, and he knows this guy was sued, too. But the guy doesn't feel like talking about it.
这个女人，Devorah，因为她欠大都会下水道管理局的钱被起诉。但她不知道他们也起诉了她隔壁的邻居。在街上转过拐角，Paul发现了一个正在进行的街区聚会。他看到一个家伙在房子前烧烤，他知道这家伙也被起诉了。但这人不想谈论它。
The next few people did talk to Paul about it, and the disruption that led to them being sued-- a health incident, a family issue. For Latanya Graves, it was when she lost her job.
接下来几个人确实和Paul谈论了它，以及导致他们被起诉的混乱——健康事件，家庭问题。对于Latanya Graves来说，是她失业的时候。
At the time, I was just trying to get back on my feet. I was laid off from Western Union.
当时，我只是试图回到我的脚上。我被西联汇款裁员了。
And how they had no one to call who could help.
而且他们如何没有可以打给帮忙的人。
Well, I would say, did you know that there was essentially one lawsuit for every four people? And they would say, no, I didn't know that.
嗯，我会说，你知道吗，每一四个人中就有一场诉讼？他们会说，不，我不知道。
All these suits on this block.
这个街区上所有这些诉讼。
Oh, on this block?
噢，在这个街区？
On this street.
在这条街上。
Wow.
哇。
This is a neighborhood where one in four people had been sued, and nobody knows that they're not the only one.
这是一个四个人中就有一个人被起诉的社区，而且没有人知道他们不是唯一一个。
Definitely nobody knew. [CHUCKLES] Nobody knew the numbers, and definitely, there was universal surprise at how prevalent it was.
绝对没有人知道。[轻笑] 没有人知道那些数字，而且绝对地，大家对它有多普遍感到普遍惊讶。
Paul stopped by a brick bungalow, Cori Winfield's house. Only it's not her house anymore, because Cori lost the house to foreclosure after the car loan. It is now Rosalyn Turner's house. Rosalyn also has had her wages garnished. She was working at Walmart, and suddenly a quarter of her paycheck started disappearing.
Paul顺路去了砖瓦平房，Cori Winfield的房子。只是那不再是她的房子了，因为Cori在汽车贷款后失去了房子的止赎权。它现在是Rosalyn Turner的房子。Rosalyn的工资也被扣押了。她在沃尔玛工作，突然她工资支票的四分之一开始消失。
Yes. After they started garnishing me, Walmart gave me a number to call. And I called them, and they wouldn't tell me much.
是的。他们开始扣押我后，沃尔玛给了我一个电话号码。我给他们打电话，他们没告诉我多少。
And Paul learned something else.
Paul还了解到了另一件事。
She had been sued by Midwest Acceptance, as well. It was the same company that Cori had been sued by.
她也被Midwest Acceptance起诉了。这就是Cori曾经被起诉的同一家公司。
Who used to live in the same house.
曾住在同一栋房子里的人。
Who used to live in the same house. So it was like, jeez.
曾住在同一栋房子里的人。所以这就像，天哪。
Rosalyn didn't know about Cori. Cori didn't know about Rosalyn. Paul was giving an entire neighborhood a status update on itself. Not that he'd set out to do that, but there he was, letting people know where they stood, relative to one another, even sometimes within the same family.
Rosalyn不知道Cori的事。Cori不知道Rosalyn的事。Paul正在给整个社区进行一次关于它自己的状态更新。虽然他不是有意那么做的，但他就在那儿，让人们知道他们相对于彼此的地位，甚至有时是在同一个家庭内部。
It happened twice where I was like, who is X? And they're like, oh, that's my daughter. I was like, do you remember them dealing with a lawsuit from so-and-so? No. I mean, I found that-- yeah, even in the same house, people don't know.
发生了两次，我像，谁是X？他们就像，噢，那是我的女儿。我像，你记得他们处理过来自某某的诉讼吗？不。我的意思是，我发现那个——是啊，即使在同一个房子里，人们也不知道。
Like here, in Dora Byrd's house. Paul asks, who's Camille Lee?
比如在这里，Dora Byrd的房子。Paul问，谁是Camille Lee？
That's my granddaughter. What's Camille Lee got to do with-- what's going on with that?
那是我的孙女。Camille Lee和——这到底是怎么回事？
Uh, sorry.
呃，抱歉。
In this one family, Dora Byrd had been sued for debt, her daughter had been sued for debt-- now she was learning her granddaughter had been sued for debt. Dora Byrd would try to help her granddaughter, now that she knows, but it will be hard, because a third of Dora's savings was garnished, too.
在这个家庭里，Dora Byrd因为债务被起诉，她的女儿因为债务被起诉——现在她得知她的孙女因为债务被起诉。Dora Byrd会尝试帮助她的孙女，既然她知道了，但这会很困难，因为Dora三分之一的积蓄也被扣押了。
On his last day in Jennings, Paul stopped by a brick house with three lawsuits.
在Jennings的最后一天，Paul顺路去了一栋有三起诉讼的砖瓦房子。
Yeah, so I went and knocked on the door, and a woman answered the second time we tried.
是啊，我去敲了门，我们第二次尝试时，一个女人开了门。
Miranda Jones. She welcomed him in.
Miranda Jones。她欢迎他进去。
We went around her backyard. Then I learned that she is a councilwoman. She's a council member in Jennings, which was a surprise.
我们绕到了她的后院。然后我得知她是市议员。她是Jennings的市议员，这令人惊讶。
Although it made sense, given the fact that she seemed to be commanding various operations by cellphone on a Saturday.
尽管考虑到她似乎在周六通过手机指挥各种行动，这也有道理。
It's on my desk. It's on my desk.
它在我的桌子上。它在我的桌子上。
Paul tells Councilwoman Jones about his data.
Paul告诉Jones议员关于他的数据。
She said, you know, you should talk to the mayor. And so she texted the mayor while I was talking to her.
她说，你知道，你应该和市长谈谈。所以我说话时她给市长发了短信。
The mayor called right back.
市长很快回了电话。
Hey, Yolanda. Hey. I got a question for you. So there's a reporter that knocked on my door. He's from the--
嘿，Yolanda。嘿。我有个问题问你。所以有个记者敲了我的门。他是从——
The mayor said she'd be happy to meet Paul in her office.
市长说她很乐意在办公室见Paul。
And then I drove right over to City Hall.
然后我直接开车去了市政厅。
They sat down in the council chambers.
他们在市议会厅坐下来。
I thought we were going to have like a kind of broader, 30,000-foot-- sort of the broader issues, like, what is this doing to my community as mayor? Like, that's the conversation that I thought we were going to have.
我以为我们会有一个更广泛的、3万英尺高度的——比如，更广泛的问题，比如，作为市长，这对我的社区正在做什么？比如，那就是我以为我们要进行的对话。
And what happened?
然后发生了什么？
So we started that way, and then she just kind of casually threw in the conversation that "I've been sued by the sewerage district, too."
所以我们以那种方式开始，然后她只是随意地在谈话中抛出，“我也被下水道管理局起诉了。”
I'm going to be honest with you. I was one of the ones that was sued, as well, falling behind because I didn't have-- you know, I lost my job.
我对你说实话。我也是被起诉的人之一，因为我没能——你知道，我失业了。
And I tried not to-- I don't think I reacted in any way, because I try not to. But yeah, I was surprised, and I was-- it's almost like unbelievable at this point. And then at that point, I turned around and I wrote down the names that I saw, like on the name-- so we were in the city council chambers. It shows what all the names of all the city council members are. So I wrote all their names down and I was like, OK, when I get home, I'm going to look at the database and see how many city council members had actually been sued.
我试着不去——我觉得我没以任何方式反应，因为我试着不去。但是是的，我很惊讶，而且我——它在这一点上几乎是难以置信的。然后在那个时候，我转过身写下了我看到的名字，比如在名字上——所以我们在市政议会厅。它显示了所有市议员的名字。所以我写下了所有他们的名字，我想，好的，当我回家时，我要看看数据库，看看有多少市议员真的被起诉了。
How many?
多少个？
So it was five of the eight city council members had been sued over a debt. It's to the point where, yeah, it's unbelievable how common it is.
所以8个市议员中有5个因为债务被起诉。到了这一点，是的，它是多么常见，简直令人难以置信。
This should not be unbelievable by this point, right? Because Paul knows the data, has walked the streets. He's stared at the map. But still, it feels unbelievable. To the mayor, too, the mayor who has detailed knowledge of this particular community, who has experienced this herself. When Paul showed her her own block on his laptop?
这一点不应该令人难以置信，对吧？因为Paul知道数据，走过街道。他盯着地图看。但它仍然感觉难以置信。对市长也是，那个对这个特定社区有详细了解，自己也经历过这件事的市长。当Paul在他的笔记本电脑上给她看她自己的街区时？
Wow. See, that's my neighbor across the street. [INAUDIBLE] is right--
哇。看，那是街对面的邻居。[听不清]就在——
You get a sense that literally like--
你有一种感觉，字面意思就是——
Every other house.
每隔一栋房子。
Yeah. It's funny--
是啊。这很有趣——
They're just suing all of us.
他们只是在起诉我们所有人。
"They're Just Suing All of Us." That was the front-page headline of the St. Louis Post Dispatch . Paul wrote a story for the paper about all this last month. So now, this thing that no one ever talks about, no one wants to talk about, that everyone is just keeping as their own private shame, was out. What happens then? How does this unusual and sudden sort of status update change things?
“他们只是在起诉我们所有人。”那是《圣路易斯邮报》的头条新闻。Paul上个月为报纸写了一个关于这一切的故事。所以现在，这件事没有人谈论，没有人想谈论，每个人都把它作为自己的私人耻辱，被揭开了。然后发生了什么？这种不寻常且突然的状态更新是如何改变事情的？
It was kind of like-- it was sad, but then it was kind of like a relief. Because I'm like, oh my goodness, you know?
这有点像——它很难过，但后来它有点像一种解脱。因为我想，噢，天哪，你知道吗？
This is the mayor, Yolanda Henderson.
这是市长，Yolanda Henderson。
To see that long list, it was just-- wow.
看到那个长名单，它只是——哇。
But you haven't talked to people about it?
但你没和人们谈过它？
No. You know, it-- that's not like a common thing you just start talking about. Hey, my wages are getting garnished. How about yours?
不。你知道，它——那不是那种你刚开始谈论的常见事情。嘿，我的工资正在被扣押。你的呢？
I heard this from a few people. Now that they know their neighbors are in the same situation, they still don't want to talk about it. It's embarrassing. Mayor Henderson had her mayor's wages garnished just six months after she was elected. A very awkward finance person had the unlucky job of telling the new mayor that she'd be seeing a deduction in her next paycheck.
我从几个人那里听到了这个。现在他们知道邻居处境相同，他们仍然不想谈论它。这很尴尬。Henderson市长在当选后仅仅6个月，她的市长工资就被扣押了。一个非常尴尬的财务人员有个倒霉的任务，要告诉新市长，她的下一张工资支票会看到扣款。
And Mayor Henderson had some questions about what that meant, which she was too embarrassed to ask, for weeks. The mayor. Not some disempowered nobody-- the mayor. It wasn't until she was giving me a tour of City Hall that she decided to finally stop by the finance office again.
Henderson市长对这意味着什么有一些问题，她不好意思问，问了好几周。市长。不是什么无能的nobody——是市长。直到她带我参观市政厅时，她才决定最后再去一次财务办公室。
All right. She's going to interview-- I got to ask you a question. My question is, on the MSD part, is it every pay period, or once a month, that 25% taken out of my pay?
好的。她要面试——我得问你个问题。我的问题是，在MSD部分，是每个发薪期，还是一月一次，那25%从我的工资中扣除？
That is--
那是——
Do you remember? I forgot to ask you. Was it every pay period, or just once?
你记得吗？我忘了问你。是每个发薪期，还是只有一次？
Every--
每个——
Every pay period. Mm-hmm.
每个发薪期。嗯哼。
Every pay period.
每个发薪期。
See, if that's the case, that's not right. That's two weeks, every two weeks. That's $300 and some. Mm-hmm.
看，如果是那样，那不对。那是两周，每两周一次。那是300多块。嗯哼。
It's standard. It's standard. It's a percentage of the income after all deductions. So it is standard.
这是标准的。这是标准的。它是扣除所有项后收入的百分比。所以它是标准的。
It is standard. Unsurprising. That was actually the most consistent reason people gave for why they don't talk about this. It wasn't that surprising.
它是标准的。不出所料。那实际上是人们为什么不谈论这件事最一致的原因。这并不令人惊讶。
They did find it surprising when they learned how many of their neighbors had been garnished. But then, just a few minutes later, it stopped feeling surprising. They already knew everyone around them had very little to draw on. It wasn't really a status update. It was just status quo.
当他们得知有多少邻居被扣押工资时，他们确实觉得惊讶。但然后，仅仅几分钟后，它就不再令人惊讶了。他们早就知道周围每个人都没什么可提取的。这并不真的是什么状态更新。这只是现状。
Chana Joffe-Walt is one of the producers of our program. You can read Paul Kiel's reporting about all this at ProPublica.org.
Chana Joffe-Walt是我们节目的制片人之一。你可以在ProPublica.org阅读Paul Kiel关于这一切的报道。
Act Four, 76-year-old Quarterback Throws Hail Mary Pass. OK, everybody. To close out show right now, I have an actual status update, a real-life status update, on somebody who was on our show a few weeks ago that many of you have written to us asking about.
第四幕，76岁的四分卫掷出万福玛丽球。好的，各位。节目快结束了，我有一个实际的状态更新，一个真实生活中的状态更新，关于几周前出现在我们节目中的一个人，你们很多人都写信问过他。
If you heard our show a few weeks ago, we had this 76-year-old man who wanted to ask this woman to marry him. He'd been visiting her for years, flying across the country to see her. He would stay at her house, hang out with her as friends, though he always wanted to be more than friends.
如果你听了几周前的节目，我们有一位76岁的老人，他想邀请一位女士嫁给他。他多年来一直拜访她，飞越全国去看她。他会待在她家，作为朋友和她混在一起，虽然他一直想成为不仅仅是朋友。
And he'd had a crush on this woman since he was the age of those girls you heard at the beginning of our program today, since high school. This girl he was about to ask to marry him was very relevant back then.
而且他从我们今天节目开始时听到的那些女孩的年龄起，从高中起，就对这个女人有好感。这个他即将邀请嫁给他的女孩在那个时候非常有存在感。
She was very popular. She was one of, you might say, the queens in high school, right?
她当时非常受欢迎。她可以说是高中里的女王之一，对吧？
Do you know where you're going to do this? Do you know where you're going to ask the question?
你知道你要去哪里做这个吗？你知道你要去哪里问这个问题吗？
Yeah. Yeah, I know where and when.
是啊。是啊，我知道在哪里和什么时候。
Where is it going to be? What can you say about that?
那会在哪里？关于那个你能说什么？
At her home. Next week.
在她家。下周。
And right before he left to fly and ask her the big question, he changed his plan. He decided that instead of asking her to marry him, he would just tell her his feelings and ask her if she wanted to be in a real committed relationship with him.
就在他出发去邀请她回答那个大问题之前，他改变了计划。他决定不再邀请她嫁给他，而是告诉她他的感受，并问她是否想和他建立一段真正承诺的关系。
And he did it. And OK, I'm just going to cut to the chase. She turned him down. Turned him down flat. No interest at all.
他做了。好的，我这就直奔主题。她拒绝了他。直接拒绝了。一点兴趣都没有。
She'd been married for 50 years. She didn't want it again, with him or anybody. Her life was full of friends. Didn't need it. That's what she said. Though, of course, that's basically the senior citizen way of saying, you know, it's not you, it's me.
她已经结婚50年了。她不想再要了，无论是和他还是任何人。她的生活充满了朋友。不需要它。这就是她说的。虽然，当然，这基本上是老年人说，“你知道，不是你，是我”的方式。
He says, right at the beginning of his visit, he got a sign of where her feelings were when he made the suggestion for the week together.
他说，就在他访问开始时，当他提出在一起一周的建议时，他得到了她感受的迹象。
I said, the one thing I would like to do is to shut down the evening, if you didn't mind, by just dancing together, closing the evening down with maybe just 15 minutes or so of dancing. She didn't agree to that. She said, well, I'm not certain about that. That's something I'll have to think about.
我说，如果你不介意的话，我最想做的一件事是，在晚上结束时，通过跳舞来结束，用大约15分钟的舞蹈来结束晚上。她没同意。她说，嗯，我不确定。那是我必须考虑的事情。
And of course, she didn't agree to that. And I know why. She didn't want any emotions to be involved, perhaps even her own, you know?
当然，她没同意。我知道为什么。她不想让任何情感介入，也许甚至是她自己的，你知道吗？
He was less sad about it than you might think, because he finally knew the truth, knew it was hopeless with her. He could move on. And he's kind of excited to move on. He says he knows now. If you meet somebody who's truly right for you, it shouldn't take years for both of you to recognize it and feel it.
他对此并不像你想象的那么难过，因为他终于知道了真相，知道和她没希望了。他可以继续前进了。而且他有点兴奋继续前进。他说他现在知道了。如果你遇到一个真正适合你的人，你们两人都不应该花几年时间去认出它并感受到它。
And if you don't, then it's time to cut it and run.
如果你不，那该砍掉它然后逃跑了。
Life's too short. He's hoping his status is going to change one more time.
生命太短了。他希望他的状态能再改变一次。
Well, our program was produced today by Chana Joffe-Walt and Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Stephanie Foo, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Robin Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Brian Reed. Our editor is Joel Lovell.
嗯，我们的节目今天由Chana Joffe-Walt和Zoe Chace、Sean Cole、Neil Drumming、Stephanie Foo、Miki Meek、Jonathan Menjivar、Robin Semien、Alissa Shipp以及Nancy Updike制作。我们的资深制片人是Brian Reed。我们的编辑是Joel Lovell。
Julie Snyder's our editorial consultant. Our technical director is Matt Tierney. Production help from Lilly Sullivan. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elyse Bergerson's our business operations manager. Elna Baker scouts stories for our show. Kimberly Henderson is our office coordinator.
Julie Snyder是我们的编辑顾问。我们的技术总监是Matt Tierney。来自Lilly Sullivan的制作帮助。Seth Lind是我们的运营总监。Emily Condon是我们的制作经理。Elyse Bergerson是我们的业务运营经理。Elna Baker为我们的节目寻找故事。Kimberly Henderson是我们的办公室协调员。
Research help from Christopher Swetala. Music help today from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis. Special thanks today to Annie Waldman, Tracy Webber, Jacob Goldstein, Ricardo Gutierrez, and Lila Margolis. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org.
来自Christopher Swetala的研究帮助。今天的音乐帮助来自Damien Graef和Rob Geddis。特别感谢今天的Annie Waldman、Tracy Webber、Jacob Goldstein、Ricardo Gutierrez以及Lila Margolis。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交换，传送给公共广播电台。我们的网站，ThisAmericanLife.org。
Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torrey Malatia, who looks into the bathroom mirror every single morning of every single day and says--
像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人，Torrey Malatia先生，他每天每天的每一个早晨，看着浴室镜子，说——
You're so pretty, like, I'm going throw you into the train tracks.
你太漂亮了，比如，我要把你扔到火车轨道上。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Ira Glass。下周回来，带着更多《美国生活》的故事。